The Joe Rogan Experience you still
overeat when you go out to eat much and
you've talked about it and I [ __ ]
resonated that so much like if I get
high before I go out to eat like and I'm
getting a good cheeseburger like I might
as well order two because I'm gonna eat
that one and I'm gonna be hungry still
I'm not even gonna [ __ ] touch my like
doesn't even phase me gluttony God damn
it it's such a pain when you're always
uh dieting and cutting weight do you
think that makes you like more prone to
doing that dude look at the reason Patty
the Baddie says gets as big as he is
because it's like you get this dismantle
disorder I strict as [ __ ] for about 10
weeks before that fight like I'd have a
little cheat meal on a Saturday but the
closer we got to the fight four or five
weeks out I was just eating so clean to
where right after
it's like I'll order two cheeseburgers a
[ __ ] some appetizers and just eat
until I'm so uncomfortable and so much
pain God look at Patty I'm gonna send
you a video Jamie this dude
um he posted today yeah Patty's and I
think I'm not who am I to [ __ ] say
but I just I mean I know that's not good
for you how much he gets up to 200
pounds
that's like me getting up to like
190. or 185. yeah that's a lot dude it's
sad it's like that's not good but it is
it gives you this mental disorder from
eating
but [ __ ] dude if you take a couple puffs
before dinner it's it depends on how
high you get there's levels of high if
you just get a nice little hide you can
the food just tastes better you can just
really enjoy it or you get too high and
you go in there and you just feel like a
bottomless pit and you're eating the
[ __ ] bread and the appetizers then
you're eating your [ __ ] other
appetizers and appetizers then you're
getting [ __ ] two cheeseburgers it's
bad sometimes Michael Easter was
actually just talking about that uh he's
a guy who wrote this book The Comfort
crisis and he wrote this book about a
study that they did where they took
these guys and they purposely starved
and play it so he could he could say it
so in that study I talked about it a few
weeks ago they took 36 men they put him
in a lab for six months and they starved
them like really starve them because
they wanted to know what happens to the
human body when we significantly
decrease our calories and lose a lot of
weight what happens to our bodies what
happens to our minds what happens to all
these different processes so it's a
really enlightening study told us a lot
about weight loss but where it started
to get interesting is that now they have
to refeed these guys and bring them back
up to a normal weight and the impacts of
the weight loss were very lasting on
these guys's Behavior so for one they
binge it one guy ate 11 000 calories a
day he had to go to the hospital for
eating so much in a meal and all of them
were eating significantly higher
calories than when they started second
is that they obsessed about food it was
on their mind all the time just as it
had been when they were starving and
there's a handful of other really
fascinating things that happened that
basically ended up bringing these guys
above the weight that they started at so
after this crazy diet they actually
ended up heavier this can tell us a lot
about diets today how we should approach
them how we should think about eating
normally once we've lost weight there's
a link in the bio if you want to learn
more check it out what I love Michael
but hey man that [ __ ] the voiceover
the the captions that's like missing all
these words I know that was weird like
that's the worst like transcription ever
it's doing it for free like if you had
to pay someone to do that well pay for
it because what is this you're cutting
off all these words like what's the
purpose of having it so you can read it
if you can't read it like it's like if
you're not listening to him and you're
reading that you're like what is he
saying there's like he's missing like
key words it's also better than not
having it incorrect
what's just him making it impacts of
weight loss what does that mean and
God's Behavior so for one they've been
Jay one let's say and then it gets to
this other one see here and he had to go
to the hospital for eatings eating what
yeah and all of them were eating
significantly what than when they
started what what if you can't hear and
you can only read that it's better than
not having it you're out of your mind no
you're out of your mind no it's it's
even something it's better to not have
it than to have it where you can't
[ __ ] read it because there's a bunch
of words missing well have you ever
watched captions normally they are about
not that good that's that's or not that
bad that's pretty bad whatever uh
program he's using that that program
sucks maybe he didn't know I built on
Instagram yeah it's probably just like a
building but interesting study is it
that bad
yeah very interesting that's uh dude
that's the it's so true every fighter
will sit here and say the same thing
after fight if you'd cut a lot of weight
and you make way and then I mean even
for me I still eat really clean leading
up to the fight but dude I see Fighters
at the [ __ ] breakfast buffet eating
like eating shitty fight day because
they made weight or after the after
weigh-ins that night they're eating
shitty they just want to eat I keep it
clean until after the fight then after
the fight I let loose a little bit but
this has been the best I've done since
usually because for me bread cheese
causes inflammation like I work with a
nutritionist Dan Garner we do he's
working on a really really cool protocol
right now a concussion protocol for me
he's done
10 plus labs for me I've been working
with them for like five years he has a
ton of data on me but we do a bunch of
like right now we'll be in uh he's
making a protocol for me outside of Camp
to eat and so he has all my all my data
but I've been doing a really good job
not overeating this each time it gets a
little bit better and it's just it's a
knowledge thing and a discipline thing
uh does he meal prep for you so he makes
you he he lives in Canada he writes it
out I have a meal prep company in uh
Arizona all Organics that makes my food
oh that's right the entire fight Camp so
they give you the exact portions oh
that's great change the game oh yeah I
don't really cook Danny cooked she would
you know full-time mom and she does hair
for a living so she'd work a couple days
a week
um but so yeah the the recharge Center
in Arizona they [ __ ] it changed the
game that's amazing yeah but this this
one I mean I got out of this camp or out
of that fight and I was like I'm ready
to go I want to [ __ ] get back to the
gym I know how hard fight Henry is how
hard of a fight aljo is how hard of a
fight anybody in the top five is I need
to get back to the gym so I you know
I've been really a lot more disciplined
these I think it's been a month now
since the fight but not eating as much
cheese and or eating as much bread if I
go out go out to eat just because I know
that [ __ ] causes inflammation in my
body and I know it's gonna make take a
little bit longer to get back to
training or if I am training and I eat
you know too much cheese and bread it's
going to cause that inflammation risk
and injury or just be [ __ ] more sore
than I need to be but yeah eating
disorder from cutting weight is a real
[ __ ] problem it's a real thing right
if I fought at my natural weight class
I'd fight at 155 if I didn't cut weight
walking around 58 59 whatever I'd fight
at 155. there's no [ __ ] chance that
I'm gonna say you know what I'm just
gonna do that I'm gonna go fight Justin
gaichi I'm gonna fight Charles like
there's no way I could go fight at 145 I
believe and be successful I'm not a tiny
35er those guys would still even be a
little bit bigger but cutting the 45 I
wouldn't kind of 35 is [ __ ] hard you
feel like you're dying your heart is
pounding you're laying in bed you kind
of are done you you 100 are dying like I
talk to my body I have to tell it like
hey you know what we're going what we're
doing fight week like we're gonna start
you know cutting cutting weight I
thought I try to tell myself like we
know we're not gonna actually die we're
gonna feel like that or whatever but
I could cut to 45 would be a lot easier
obviously 55 would be the easiest but I
I wish more guys would but then again
like aljo he weighs how much right now I
don't know 160 days Davidson Davidson
figuredo I wonder if he goes to 35 oh
he's fighting he's fighting 25 again
he's gonna do it again he he said he was
mad at me for saying that I didn't think
he's going to be at 25 again but he's
sure but he's talked about that he's
stacked though is he I've never really
been around him God he's thick but when
you're a certain height
I feel like you ha like you have to but
then again look at Henry he's [ __ ]
five three and he's [ __ ] doing it
yeah so I guess it depends on how thick
you are but how tall is figareto Jamie I
five see he could fight it 35 but